we've discovered that a growing number
of children are being excluded from
mainstream education for drugs and
violence why did you get excluded from
your previous school throwing our rocket
teacher during a rock wade cocaine hands
up if you think it's easy to get drugs
we've been given rare access to two
pupil Referral Units known as Prue's
which are set up to educate excluded
children when I go back to the wall
after a couple hours in it first on the
teacher I'd got involved and the teacher
got kicked for accident by who
I'm if quite a lot of reasons to be fair
fight in smoking under the zoom but
Prue's have a bad reputation a breeding
ground for gangs and conveyor belt to
prison they're saying right here's the
most difficult children in this borough
deal with it and we're saying thanks so
are they part of the problem
blaming proves for and have their first
grooming young people into gangs is the
same as blaming hospital was having too
many sick people
[Music]
Tai is passionate about making music but
when it comes to education he was
considered a bad apple at that point I
was proud of him
wait yeah I'm the worst kid in the
school
yeah I was just like I'm not gonna get
grants lost the point I might as well
just be babbling enjoy myself it was a
detention every day emails every day and
then ty would come home and I'd be like
time why are we going through this again
you know we've just gone through this
yesterday and the day before and the day
before and it was constant and it was a
to a point and I was mentioned the
earlier I actually was receiving emails
when he weren't at the school to say
that he's got a detention many weren't
even there in a school of 2,000 children
he had the worst behavior record student
taught a teacher had a knife on me and
they didn't search me or anything they
just said that I had a knife on me and
they just expose me from there
and but I didn't really think it was
because I don't know American I may have
made maybe so this bad apple gets
expelled and placed in a basket with all
the other bad apples in a pupil Referral
now some argue that lumping difficult
children together in one place is a
recipe for disaster others that it's the
only option either way these referral
units are a reality for a growing number
of children in the UK and when someone
comes here you're probably bracing
yourself for quite a problems to deal
with right we get a referral through for
a young person that may have been
permanently excluded for having a knife
and distributing drugs in school let's
say on paper can be particularly badly
but the truth is behind each person that
comes to us there's a story and I think
our job here rather than just continuing
where they left off from in a mainstream
environment it's about trying to rewind
that story and strip back some of those
layers a lot of these kids have been
through more than most adults would in
60 70 years of living if I'm being
honest for a young person to witness the
levels of domestic violence that they
may witness taking place in home or for
a young person to be out on the street
and see one of their friends witness one
of their friends die in front of them is
not something that most adults will ever
experience exclusions are on the rise
but particularly in relation to violence
in school and drug offenses and the two
things are sometimes connected 7700
children were excluded in the last
recorded year that's forty a day but new
figures from drug policy think-tank
volte-face seen exclusively by Sky News
show that drug and alcohol related
exclusions in secondary schools have
increased by 60 percent in the last five
years
some argue mainstream schools need a new
approach to tackling the problem if
someone is using drugs or dealing drugs
and that is a safeguarding concern we
should be worried about their well-being
and be concerned about that and actually
we should be looking to support them
rather than exclude them at ties pupil
referral unit there are frequent drug
awareness lessons and kids can be honest
with teachers without risking exclusion
but pupils here say regular schools are
clueless about what's going on
when you walk into a mainstream school
you can have a weapon on you can have
drugs and you can you could even it's so
easy to bring weapons into a meeting in
school literally and like you see
students sneaking into the bathroom
coming out to any minute 20 minutes
later oh hi I'm taking drugs yeah and
what was the school's reaction to that
the teachers are oblivious to the fact
that it's going on
fifteen-year-old Chiara says she had
angered problems that led to fights
until finally she was excluded in June
last year Paige Christopher has ADHD and
was also excluded for fighting she found
no other mainstream school would take
her because of her bad behavior record
she says drugs were rife in her former
school to today obviously they might get
all of the drugs and they know what to
cost you to do so and then they keep
saying to other people like their
friends and their friends will know
people will just said it on the whole
school to us I wouldn't actually do NHS
data shows there's been a 50% increase
in 11 to 15 year olds taking illegal
drugs in the last two years and while
drug users are getting younger
there's also been a huge rise in
convictions for children selling drugs
one reason is likely to be the growth in
county lines drug dealing we're
increasing numbers of children are being
recruited as runners
do you have children here who are
involved in county line structure yes
they must be under threat at times what
sort of experiences you had around that
and we've had people turning up here
looking for people before with weapons
and outside of the front of the school
we've had people outside of school have
been attacked people outside of school
that have been stabbed in school we
provide a really safe environment for
young people which is why I believe they
turn up every day and they want to be
here but don't think this is just a
London issue let's take you to another
pupil referral unit Grove Academy in
Harrogate North Yorkshire they're
watching a film about London gangs but
it reflects their lives I mean these are
London gangs they're dealing drugs and
that sort of thing is that is that also
going on around here yeah yeah small
towns and stuff it's not just big cities
small towns and everything people don't
understand that though have you been
tempted to carry a knife yourself I've
carried a knife
oh yeah yeah in what circumstances saved
it it can be helpful yeah I mean not
really
yeah because I didn't you know but like
not using it like you pulling it out and
like most people will start walking
backwards and then you've got times so
you either run or fight it slims what
your body does done it you know wouldn't
it be better just to run sometimes you
could get blocked in the idea is to get
more together be therapeutic and
socialising the children arriving at
these referral units come with a range
of problems including drug addiction the
art teacher at grave academy says one
student hasn't turned up today almost
certainly because of drugs 52% of our
students
take drugs on a regular basis right and
how does that impact on teaching them
there are mental health issues self
harming this one pupil that I think he's
broken his knuckles twice since he's
been here because he gets so cross that
he'll hit the walls and then we have to
get into a nae
or get the month taken to A&E the
government plans to make drug education
mandatory in all primary and secondary
schools by 2020 but is it enough some
kids get deeply entangled while in
mainstream education and even in
Harrogate County lines dealing has taken
grip one mother agreed to tell us her
child's story he was told to sell drugs
and he had to or they would hurt his
family that was that was the thing he
kept running away from home and we
couldn't understand why because he had a
good home yeah and it was the fact of he
thought they would hurt his family
really made him run away so they must
have they must have must have really put
the frighteners up they're really dead
really how did they do that
you know they showed him videos of
people on the phones that they'd hurt I
believe I didn't think this sort of
thing really existed but to actually be
involved in it and see what it can do
was a nightmare that's the only way I
can I just I didn't want to know how to
put it into words it could break your
family very very easily there's people
there already looking for the vulnerable
ones regardless of what school they go
to but it was here that's a it was the
prove that actually supported him
that's for Matt if from my perspective
you know you know they gave him the
support to come through the other side
and what would have happened if some the
people who hadn't stepped in honestly I
don't think it'd have been here but
should pupil Referral Units be picking
up the pieces or do mainstream schools
need to take a new approach and support
rather than exclude
I think part of the problem is the fact
that schools in many ways have been
expensively gatekeepers of social values
and social behavioral norms and
societies yet to catch up with the
reality of the everyday experience of a
lot of young people and years of drugs
being an endemic part of their
adolescent experience the sad truth is
that mainstream schools want to do more
and I think the issue is that with
schools losing a lot of the income local
cotton income they get they have to make
decisions about what goes then the
English teacher can't go with the math
teacher can't go the geography teacher
can't go they need to be in class
teaching young people so what you find
that you then lose is that pastoral wrap
around care in a little bit closer so
that we've got more of a discussion
forum at these pupil Referral Units
rather than a zero tolerance to drugs
they talk about it rather than isolate
children for bad behavior they look for
root causes the children here say
mainstream schools should have the same
approach wait okay
and how was the school dealing with that
and they didn't really deal with their
moral ashes took you out straightaway as
soon as I find out lightly taking drugs
and there's not really any support that
are from me she was cool you know what
they didn't even find out and it was bad
because I was doing it while I was at
school we used to like go off on our
breaks take smoke weed and then come
back sit in a lesson go do the same
again on lunch break and they had no
idea until they actually like cause with
the honors then we just got excluded a
away so should there be more support and
understanding in schools those who take
the decisions to expel say it's never
done lightly what I used to ask myself
in the situations where I had to
consider expulsion was if I don't expel
a child for this what would i expel them
for you never know how many other
children you saved or prevented from
bringing weapons drugs other banned
things into school you never know how
many other two and you've put off from
doing that by having if you aren't made
an exam
or of another child in that situation
it's a really hard thing to weigh up
with but I can honestly say whilst I was
always upset when I had to make those
decisions
I slept easy afterwards you can't enjoy
that sort of thing you can try and take
satisfaction from doing it with
integrity the next time I catch up with
ty he's just been offered a place in a
Sixth Form College and is on track to
get several GCSEs haven't been told at
his last school he wouldn't get any a
lot of the kids that go there go from no
hope to some hope and that is that is
what education is about not every pupil
referral unit is well-run but many of
the kids we've met here in London and
Harrogate say their lives have been
turned around since I've been here my
grades have gone up Blair I can focus
more it's easier do you want to go back
to mainstream adoption no they may be
considered the bottom rung of the
educational ladder but perhaps
mainstream schools can learn a lesson or
two from pupil Referral use there was a
single young person out there that wants
to do badly they may say they do as a
defense mechanism but there was not a
single young person that wants to be in
a gang that wants to go into the go to
prison that wants to stab someone that
wants to drug deal that wants to foul
and mess up their whole education and
they may say they want to time and time
and time again and it's about changing
that mindset it's about making every
young person here believe that they have
the potential to achieve
you